hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the global chess.com chess Festival
uh finals uh it is uh Wesley so versus
nikal sarin and this is the third game
of their match the match started by
Wesley winning the first game it was a
very nice win uh nihal tried to go for
the petrol but Wesley was a quick to
deal with it I think it took him some 36
moves then uh just making a resign he
had to give up his Queen and there was
no way to continue the game as he would
lose another piece then the second game
where nickel had the white piece ended
with a draw and this is now the third
game so let's check it out Wesley has
the white pieces and he again opens with
E4 he really liked how his game uh with
the white pieces ended in game one when
he had played the petrol but now nihal
plays G6 he goes for the modern defense
uh sorry about that uh and now Wesley
goes for Pawn to D4 as one usually does
when black doesn't want to fight for the
center Bishop to G7 and now Knight to C3
or rather black does fight for the
center but with the pieces not with the
pawns uh Pawn to D6 with Bishop to E3
and now Pawn to A6 and it's a very very
standard setup of the of the modern
defense so it's been attempted uh quite
a few times even on the top level uh
Magnus cross and even played it uh I
believe he once lost that uh Knight each
and he defeated Wei with it and uh I
believe why nehal prepared this is
because
um Wesley also lost the game last year
in the Magnus cross and Invitational to
Yani punish you when Nepal played this
exact setup with the black pieces uh so
you know it's uh it's definitely in
there that uh nihal uh prepared probably
uh with that game in mind but it's also
interesting if Wesley prepared as well
once you lose the game you have to see
why he lost it did win to prepare
something better if it ever comes up
again so here Queen to D2 it's the
standard way of dealing with such
positions you want to have the option of
going Bishop to H6 at some point and of
course you want the castle Queen side as
black is most likely on a castle King
side and then it's gonna be a Race So
Knights the D7 we have H4 and now H6 we
have Queen side Castles by Wesley Ponta
B5 and now Ponta F3 strengthening the F4
pawn and of course preparing to continue
pushing on the king side Bishop to B7
and now comes uh Pawn to A3 and pawn to
A3 is a new move so now already as of
move nine we have a completely new game
there are a couple of other very nice
games that read you this exact same
position for example then you'll do both
had this against the Vladimir malakov in
the Moscow Blitz tournament uh in 2015
where Knight to H3 was played and it is
in fact the top move recommended by the
engine the one that do both played but
here Wesley was Pawn to E3 and let's see
how the game continues uh Rook the C8 of
course nihal is preparing C5 he wants to
open up the C file and have the Rook
control the C file the queen will most
likely come to C7 and this will put a
lot of pressure on that white king So
King the B1 uh Pawn to C5 captures
captures and now Knight G to E2 the
Knight with ideas of coming to F4 or
maybe even uh maybe even G3 Knight back
to D7 again opening up the uh C file for
the rook and you want to have access to
F6 and E5 with this Knight so Knights
the D5 uh and now Knight G2 F6 Wesley
trades we have Knight captures with
track Knight captures on F6 and now you
could continue with something solid like
Knight to C3 or Bishop to D4 to counter
anyhow strong bishop and G7 but Wesley
goes for uh what we all want Wesley to
go for and that is Ponte H5 now this is
a move that uh
now I shouldn't work and usually black
will have a very nice game but for some
reason it most often works so Knight
captures on H5 and the Wesley gives up
the exchange Rook captures an h5g
captors and the Knights the G3 and now
nikhail has to figure out how to set up
some sort of a defense does he have time
for H4 to kick away the Knight and then
maybe something on if Knight F5 Rook to
G defend the bishop uh he says Ah you
can have that pawn I'm gonna go Rook to
G8 right away and okay Knight captures
an H5 we have Bishop to h8 and now Pawn
to G4 so starting the attack but it's
still unclear how Wesley will reach that
black king with uh Queen to C7 putting
pressure on the C2 pawn and now C3 uh
makes sense you do not want this C2 Pawn
to be a Target and also C3 uh sort of uh
well Limits The Power of this bishop on
h8 and here nikal goes Rook to d8 and
it's a it's a correct idea but uh maybe
you wanna play it even faster and by
play it even faster I mean don't play
right away first play D5 and only after
he captures on D5 now you play Rook 38
with already Rook having something to do
and now if let's say Knight to F4
defending the pawn now Rook G5 and now
the pawn will fall so that's one way to
do it but nihal starts with Rook to d8
and now he gives Wesley a little bit of
time Bishop to D4
we have pawned the E5 and now Bishop
back to F2 we have Pawn to D5 now uh
Bishop to H4 attacking the rook and d8
Rook D7 and now Queen captures an H6 and
this position is still perfectly fine
for black in fact uh the position is
objectively even winning for black but
it's very very hard to play with all of
these pieces in front of your king D
characters on e4 as you should play this
Rook captures on D7 Queen captures and
now Knight the F6 with check you don't
have time for some Queen captures on h8
followed by Knight to F6 check because
there's Queen to D1 checking between
moves so don't blunder that so Knight to
F6 check we have Bishop captures on F6
uh Queen captures an F6 now with the
constant thread of Checkmate on E7 and
even though this is still fine for black
this I mean this is so uncomfortable at
the place so e captures an F3 uh you you
don't really gain anything by giving a
check if Queen to D1 check just King to
A2 and now even if you go for something
like Bishop to D5 there's a C4 and
there's no way to open up the bishop
because uh well if you play B captures
and C4 then you just get checkmated so
you you can't really afford to go for
the attack so e captures an F3 creating
a beautiful pass Pawn on F3 while
defending against any Checkmate threats
here and the King to C1 now now Wesley
improves the position of his King and no
longer he has uh does he have to worry
about something like Queen to D1 with
check so Queen to C7 uh in the now we
have Pawn to A4 and without the spawn to
a form of Wesley is really without a
move
uh if Wesley doesn't figure out
something really quickly uh then nikal
will just play E4 E3 E2 and win the game
there's just nothing Wesley can do here
so he has to find some play and A4 does
just that now he wants to free up his
light Square Bishop to continue the
attack against the black king uh Bishop
to C6 and now Bishop to G3 preparing
Bishop captures on E5 and you should
even allow this best way to continue
this is Bishop to D5 and now if Bishop
captures and E5 just Queen E7 now you're
attacking the queen you're attacking the
bishop uh there's no good way to deny
black the queen trade if you go Queen F5
just Queen G5 check forces the queen
trade so this would be completely
winning for for nihal uh but he goes to
Rook the G6 and now he gives up uh the
back rank for Wesley to use for his
Queen so Queen to h8 to check King to E7
and now Bishop to D3 attacking The Rook
here and it's a very very tricky
position uh there are some moves that
there are available here like Rook Dev 6
Pawn to F2 but it's very very hard to
hold yeah Rook a pawn to F2 was played
now if the bishop ever moves you just
promote the spawn to Queen so Bishop to
H for check King to D6 and now Bishop
captures on F2 eliminating that pass
Pawn uh Rook the E6 uh and now preparing
to push the E Pawn and queen the f8 with
check with Queen t7 Queen to B8 with
check Queen to C7 and queen back to f8
with check and now uh nikal could settle
for a draw here with um with queen t7
and sort of go for a repetition of moves
but I think it's because he lost game
one that he didn't want to settle for a
draw he played Rook to E7 instead of
blocking with the queen and now uh the
position is completely winning for
Wesley but I will not tell you how uh
it's up to you guys to figure it out and
I know some of you can already see it
but just in case feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Wesley while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the move
that is pretty much always the winning
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is of course Pawn
to B4 that's the good stuff a fun fact
actually Wesley missed it he did not
play the move as they were both very low
on time some 10 seconds on the clock so
and it requires quite a lot of
calculation but point is you cannot
allow Bishop to C5 if you allow Bishop
to C5 is just game over uh now if you go
King to D7 it doesn't really matter
because there's always Bishop to F5 with
check and then after the king moves you
still have Bishop to C5 with chicken
after King D5 just Queen H6 with the
Bishops covering D6 and E6 Queenie a
queen to D2 check uh will just be game
over and the other thing is what if
Black Goes King to D5 it's also a
possibility and now you play Queen to H6
you cut off the black king from behind
and now after Rook D6 let's say
attacking the queen look at this bishop
to E4 with check beautiful Bishop
sacrifice and if the bishop is captured
you just deliver a nice checkmate with
uh Queen E3 King D5 and queen to D4
Checkmate uh sorry not going to D4 uh
Queen to D3 Checkmate and if you don't
uh
capture the bishop if you go King back
to D6 then it's a bit of a bit of a a
longer variation but still a completely
winning one Queen to f8 check King to D7
Queen captures an F7 Rook E7 Bishop to
F5 check King to d8 and now Bishop to H4
and you will simply trade down into a
completely winning end game Queen to D6
and now you're just the king a queen of
f8 Bishop to E8 and now you trade Bishop
captures Queen captures Queen captures
King captures you advance the pawn to A5
and with the extra passed g-pawn this
will be completely winning as its
Bishops of the same color so that's uh
that's how you do it but this is a rapid
game they were both very long time
Wesley misses B4 and he plays Bishop to
F5 which allows the knee-hal to bounce
back and play this game he can play some
like Bishop to D7 or B captors on A4
which he does so Queen to H6 with check
and now you have to play Rook the E6
Rook the E6 is the
the only mood that keeps nehal in the
game point is that after Bishop captures
F captures and queen to f8 check you can
escape King 37 Queen F7 tracking the C8
and now after king queen captures an E6
King to B7 and yes okay white does have
a past G Pawn but with some nice moves
you can you can play this however after
Queen to H6 check nihal blunders and he
plays King to D5 and now he just runs
into a forced Checkmate in four uh and
Wesley of course spots it Queen to D2
with check King to C4 and now Queen to
D3 with check King to B3 and now Pawn to
see for a discovery from the queen if
you go to A2 then Queen to A3 is
Checkmate so King the B4 was played and
now of course Queen to C3 ends the game
as this is now again checkmate
uh so yeah very nicely played by by
Wesley winning both the game one and
three so both of his games with the
white pieces uh Wesley wins both of
these games with the black piece
ascended in a draw so three to one in
the first match or basically it's the
same match only divided uh by by two
days uh for four games
um in the first day four games the
second day so there will have there will
be four more games today we'll see if
Niha will be able to bounce back or will
Wesley just continue this uh well
incredible chess playing
uh well
what he's doing
uh so yeah uh that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh like I said
beautifully done by Wesley and it's a
it's a tricky tricky line that I I
mentioned uh a lot of strong players are
playing like even Magnus played it a few
times uh this uh exact same setup uh
with uh Pawn day six and you can plan uh
but it's just always very very hard for
black and even this line Rook captures
on H5 it should not work for white black
can defend but it's just so difficult to
play and it's another another example of
how we we cannot play like engines as
much as we train with engines and as
much as we watch the engines play we
just can't uh play like engines because
once our King is in the open uh there
are Bishops and knights coming for our
King you can't just relax and say okay
this is perfectly fine uh you will feel
threatened and you will make make a
mistake especially in time travel uh so
once again hope you guys enjoyed it
we'll see what happens on day two yeah I
would like to thank sophosphere and some
Finance the shadow subramanian Aaron is
the best fiance uh Marcus grebel and the
Wesley the greatest for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day